Brian all right I am stuck at LGA with
the SFO blues again what do I do well if
you're actually at the airport you know
it can take forever to wait in line or
wait on the phone so I actually
recommend if you have lounge access or
maybe even springing 50 bucks to get
into your airline lounge those agents
are actually you know generally the best
agents to rebook you and can look at
options that others may not be able to
offer you are a mural one-percenter you
you are you pay for better agents
exactly yeah you know paying a little
bit for some perks can pay off but if
you're if you're not at the airport
definitely leverage social media the
airlines have really ramped up
especially for this storm they knew it
was coming I called Delta yesterday and
got through right away although I am you
know that one percenter so you can't be
too surprised but you got to be faby and
be your own advocate so you but it's
also part of the way you book right if
you're trying to fix at the last minute
then you're fixing it the wrong way you
should have booked in a certain way what
do I need to do the next time I'm
booking a ticket to get it right well in
general airlines are going to take care
of their elite travelers the most so
this is why you know when we say it may
make sense to give a little you know
your loyalty to an airline even if
you're a silver level flyer you're gonna
get recom adada generally over people
who don't have elite status so you know
getting an airline credit card and
getting those elite miles can pay off
because times like this or when you
really need those parts even if you're
not getting the upgrades anymore cuz
airlines are you know selling first
class seats on the points guy web page
we have a guy who just went to Havana
and survived what did you learn in
Havana oh wise one I was hoping you'd
ask that because I was hoping uh that to
get on Americans a non-stop flight so
that the biggest tip I have is that it's
extremely difficult to book travel I
actually booked the day up that Obama
made that announcement it's almost
impossible to book hotels online I had
to fly through Grand Cayman because
those charters which you can now get on
if you are a journalist are booked for
weeks in advance so don't book a
last-minute trip to Cuba if you want to
experience it the right way wait do they
know who the points guy is in Cuba when
you show up are you el tipo Punk'd oh
yes there were throngs there were
throngs of people yeah el hombre de
puntos yeah I was signing off
slee all of us travel Olivia's on a
plane every weekend it seems in our
social life when are they going to
expand business class are they taking
more rows on a given airline to business
class now absolutely it's all about the
premium travelers you know we saw
JetBlue just launched a really amazing
business class on the New York to LA and
san fran flights at a really great price
it's all about business class in fact
first class on international flights is
shrinking and business class is growing
you know the economy's booming people
are willing to pay double for business
class but not 5x4 first Olivia where are
you going this weekend I'm staying here
Oh next my next shipment Aspen and oh
dear points guy could you please tell me
how to get to Aspen direct for under two
grand I would I would love to know that
I'll ask you in the break in the
meantime more my neck of the woods is
premium economy the new business premium
economy it's not necessarily the new
business airlines are actually giving
that to the elite travelers because
they're no longer getting upgraded you
know people are paying for business so
it's kind of like the consolation prize
if your company is not gonna shell out
for business you know the airline's
still want to reward you for loyalty but
not with that you know lie flat bed
gotta pay for it any points guy there is
something consistent to every piece of
advice you've given this morning which
is be important exactly and you don't
have to spend a ton to be important it
may be getting the right credit card or
you know taking one of those mileage
runs to get elite status although the
airlines are making that harder but the
game still does exist so that's why I
got to read my site Brian tell us about
your website you have been at an
entrepreneurial spirit you have invented
this industry are you chases friend are
you Barclays friend are you Starwood's
friend or are you the enemy no I'm i
would say I'm the friend everyone can
win in the loyalty points game you know
it's it the credit card companies do
advertise with my site you know and they
want their consumers to get the most
value out of their points so you know I
just help consumers get the most value
in travel amazingly so that the credit
card companies are paying the airlines
so I I think if anything the airlines
might be a little kid right but I'm
everyone's Freddie oh thank you so much
Brian I hate you you went for $89 to
like some Island in the station
Brian I will I will be calling you after
the show